hello freak [ __ ] I read an amazing
book called our political selves I think
it was called that about half of our
political opinion is gin is genetically
determined so genetically determined
yeah so and it which makes sense so
liberalism and conservatism basically
liberalism is concerned with fairness
within the group and equality within the
group and an acceptance of outsiders as
possible for possible inclusion in the
group conservatism is focused on
hierarchy and sort of law and order and
a suspicion of outsiders and they're
very very powerful evolutionary adaptive
evolutionary reasons for both of those
worldviews and they've done to us
studies with identical twins that were
adopted at Birth and compared them to
fraternal twins and there's a far higher
concordance of a political opinion in
identical twins that were adopted at
Birth and put in different kinds of
families than with fraternal twins so
that means that our political apparently
it's around 50% of our political beliefs
are genetically determined which means
that those beliefs had adaptive value in
our evolutionary past which means that
the argument I'm right you're completely
wrong and you shouldn't exist is a false
argument it that the country actually
needs both parties very very badly in
that a healthy society has conservatism
and liberalism in a kind of dynamic
tension where yes they might fight they
might argue but they are they're roughly
proportional in the population and equal
weight is given to those two competing
values was it taken into consideration
that when these people are adopted that
growing up adopted without your
biological parents puts you in a certain
mindset automatically and that maybe it
wasn't necessarily a genetic thing but
it was a circumstantial or a nurturer so
they compared identical twins who were
genetically identical of course that
were adopted to fraternal twins who were
adopted to understand yes and fraternal
twins are not genetically identical but
they still come from the same body they
succumb no no but is it their DNA is
there at our individual yes right so
both sets of twins were adopted right so
they all went through that whatever that
is that
that process the effects of that
whatever they are what are one shared
DNA exact duplicates of their DNA the
other set of twins don't they're
fraternal so the the twins that shared
identical DNA were far more likely to
have the same political beliefs than the
fraternal twins in other words the
genetic component was influencing their
beliefs and the environmental component
was not as much compared to the
fraternal twins there's an amazing book
and it really it mate to me it makes
sense like both worldviews clearly were
needed to keep our society healthy and
strong and safe I mean god I mean a
country that was run completely by
liberals would get overrun by you know
the enemy state next-door immediately
right a country that was completely run
by conservatives would never get overrun
by the enemy but it would be a heartless
and brutal society right where the poor
weren't taken care of and etc etc so you
can't have one or the other you need
both right kind of dynamic tension so it
makes genetic sense that it works that
way just like there would be genetic
variations and all sorts of different
aspects of people height and personality
and all those different things yeah I
mean it's or character traits right I
mean they're partly genetic and they're
partly determined by experience so right
um you know courage or whatever
generosity sensation-seeking
right is a genetic trait but you can you
can your since your impulse towards
sensation-seeking
is also determined by your experiences
in life right I don't know what the
proportions are but in terms of
political belief it's roughly 50/50 your
experience in life is about 50%
responsible for your political beliefs
and the and the other 50% is genetics
we're always looking for one reason
right where I was looking forward nature
or nurture we're looking for one of it
we're not looking at this just whole
soup of different entangled influences
yeah that create a person yeah it is
really interesting when I tell people
that their genetics determine half of
their political view they get really
upset right they want to be completely
self determining right I mean that
people want to think that they're
completely whatever they are they've
created themselves and certainly
something as emotional as political
belief they don't want to think that
it's wired into their DNA at all but you
know that's that's the truth of it well
just determinism in general I mean I
remember the first time I was ever
really deeply explained to me by Sam
Harris I was rejecting it like almost
instant like I didn't want to just be
able to minded about it I wanted to go
that well you know you could pull
yourself up you could figure yeah you do
what your wits will power you decide
what you want to do with your life but
not really necessarily I mean listen
when I was young I was a really good
distance runner right and I ran a 1/2
mile mile on up to 10,000 meters
marathon whatever I ran for 12 for the
mile was a pretty decent time right I
really wanted to be like the fastest
mile er in the world right and I trained
as fast as anyone who's ever trained as
hard as anyone's ever trained and I my
ceiling was 412 and that was genetically
determined sorry like you can run 130
miles a week like I did for months on
end and still not go to the Olympics
yeah there's no doubt about it I mean ah
as a mixed martial arts commentator the
the big factor that you can't do
anything about is power some people are
born with striking power and it doesn't
make any sense they have they look
exactly the same they look just like a
person who can't hit nearly as hard as
them right right yeah I mean my
understanding is the sort of sequencing
of muscle groups in coordination that
result in that kind of power is amazing
it's bone structure as well there's
other variables there's actually they
did the the geometry of the shoulder
like how wide your shoulders are in
terms of the hips to waist ratio there's
a lot of different factors I was kidding
yeah that's why the reasons why men can
hit so much harder than women it's
literally the shape of the hips women's
hips are wider the legs go inward more
it's a different sort of right we had a
goal advantage which is probably
connected to the speed you can throw a
baseball at yeah obviously she looked at
the same skeletal yeah apparently boys
and girls can throw pretty much the same
until puberty and then it really splits
and and so it's probably for that reason
you